thanks so much good morning everybody so
thanks
for the kind invitation for all the
effort and sweat to umuch and matt for
setting up this wonderful workshop
so for the next 45 minutes or so we
shall be concerned with correlations
area loss and stability of open and
thermal quantum mini body system
christian joint work with a number of
people specifically with michael who's
also here there's admittedly a very long
title
but the point of the talk is rather
short namely that in a way that there's
more to hamiltonian complexity
complexity than to look at ground states
of local hamiltonians and
that it can also be interesting to look
at thermal states of open and civilian
systems
so these are the cradle questions of
this
workshop like whether
ground states of natural quantum systems
can succinctly be described and we heard
about the local amatonian problem being
qima complete and
steps about steps towards the holy grail
of the quantum pcp theorem in maths um
and the ritz talk so in this story we
shall be less concerned with the first
bullet point on this list but rather
with a second asking whether this
exponential complexity of general
quantum systems in a way persists at
high temperature so after all how about
thermal and lavillion open
many body systems anyway the type of
question we have in mind is pretty much
similar to the usual questions the
questions when asked in the ground state
context
say
for example concerning the the
short-rangeness and clustering of
correlations in ground states say we
know that if you have a minibody system
which has a uniform gap above the ground
set energy then all correlation
functions would decay exponentially with
the distance and the lattice as has
first been shown by by matte um using
early products and bounce
now this kind of short rangedness of
correlations can as we know be sharpened
and made more precise by um
notions of area laws for the entirement
entropy so this locality is inherited by
the locality of interactions and this is
proven to hold true for
gapped one-dimensional systems again
proven by math using lee province and
bounds and also like for free quasi-free
bosonic and fermionic many body systems
in arbitrary dimensions as we have shown
and it may or may not be true for
arbitrary and gap models in in any
dimension
um we also know that this notion of an
area law is very much intertwined with
the question of how difficult it is to
approximate many body states with tensor
network states say with matrix product
states in one-dimensional systems and
there's this beautiful polynomial time
algorithm for approximating ground
states of one-dimensional gapped local
hamiltonians again by uh people in in
the audience here so this is kind of the
the flavor the type of question we have
in mind throughout the talk yet
apply it to the world not of ground
states but to
thermal and
open uh many body systems that's kind of
the mindset
of
of this whole
okay so specifically why is the
latter
interesting so at the beginning of all
this is the question of what happens if
you not only have local many-body
interactions hamiltonian interactions in
the lattice but on top of that the
system is subject to kind of dissipation
from the outside
obviously such a situation is ubiquitous
in physics in a way every quantum system
is an open system to some extent but
this seems specific specifically
interesting in the context of
uh precisely engineered dissipation so
in a in a situation where one has a
system in the lab sitting there in the
lab under precisely controlled
conditions and where one can in a way
engineer the dissipation can kind of
make use of that and then as a knob to
play and turn with in in one way or or
the other hyphen
um so this is a here's a bit of a
physics motivation of this why this is
so much studied in the specifically in
the physics literature you can think say
of systems of code atoms in optical
lattices which are made from counter
propagating laser light where you really
have a controlled many body systems in
the lab also undergoing uh dissipation
there's a called atoms component to this
one can think of an um quantum optics
component where people really think of
engineering precisely engineering the
the noise that you have
to given a figure of merit and there's a
many body component to this which is of
course in the in in the focus um
in the focus of this talk so why is why
are these kind of dissipative open many
body systems so much studied
these days and why are people so excited
about it but to start with of course
there's this the basic question of um
just looking at the interplay of
hamiltonian
many body interactions and dissipative
like open systems uh dynamics in one way
or the other one one can think of like
dissipative quantum phase transitions
one can think of notions of noise driven
criticality or ideas of topological
order but not of ground states but of
stationary states of many body
m systems
i could even think of dissipative
quantum computing this is quite an
appealing picture of quantum computing
where has a many body system given what
just lets it cool down in time and reads
out one qubit at the end of the day and
this is a bqpp machine it's a universal
quantum computer and quite a an
appealing way of thinking of quantum
computing where it's not there's no
control but you just have one fixed
levian sitting there and the system
cools down and that gives rise to a
universal and quantum computing
and
um
one can even dream of like passive
dissipative topologically protected
quantum memories in low dimension and i
will um comment
on on this also later um in in this talk
this is kind of the the mindset of this
open systems um
setting
so
the
role of the hamiltonian gap in this
ground state world is largely taken over
by the lavillion gap in the civilian
open systems world and one can even
think of in a way of notions of living
complexity reminding of notions of
hamiltonian complexity and then kind of
find the work and largely translate
yes maybe we'll get this later but is
there any way to make a formal
connection between hamiltonian and
louisvillian gap
uh
well
yes and no we get this later yeah thank
you
um
yes i will yeah yes
um
oh these are all interesting questions
can i kind of just postpone them a
little bit
but when i have the definition of a
living and so yeah i mean yeah indeed um
okay so one can ask lots of questions um
what is already happening
um
so
for example um how is the like how is
like how what's the connection between
like uh mixing in time and mixing in
space in a way so one can think of
questions of how the closing of the
living gap is related to a clustering of
correlations one can think of area laws
anticipative systems notions of
stability
uh topologically dissipative memories
and if time allows
well let's see how it goes we will
address these questions um
in this talk and then in the second part
of the talk we will come back to the
original question of this complexity of
thermal high temperature states and
will ask questions
well the more physics the question
whether temperature is intensive or
local again about correlations and
clustering of correlations in terms of
anybody's systems and
about the computational complexity of
computing expectation values building
upon well shockingly work by matt what
can i say
okay so correlations in open
many body systems
okay so here's the lavillion so the
setting we are in is the lovilian
setting
uh reflecting memoryless
open systems dynamics and this is often
to an overwhelmingly good approximation
uh an approximation of the true open
system many body dynamics which means
that the equation of motion of the
system is replaced by such a
an equation of motion here where the
right hand side is called the the
lavillion which is the generator of the
dynamical semi group
um
so this is still effective system
dynamics one does not it's explicitly
speak of the environment this is kind of
inbuilt in the right-hand side where
these lk's are the so-called limp blood
operators that reflect the open system
dynamics and define what's going on
um
in the in in the in the open system
dynamics
so in a similar way as
hamiltonian
terms which are natural antibody systems
are usually local especially local on a
graph one usually thinks of these limp
blood
operators being geometrically local on
some
some graph so you would have like
on-site noise or nearest neighbor noise
or so but not everybody being coupled to
everybody and again
like hamiltonian terms are usually
bounded one would have a uniform
operator norm upper bound or each of
these lobelian terms just to keep the
coupling strength in a way bounded in
in the problem
now the
role of the
ground state is largely taken over by
the stationary state
of
such a
lovillian that's well it's just the
stationary state that's often taken to
be a full rank then the levine is called
a so-called primitive levillion and
satisfying detailed balance that's a
rather natural condition um say
like
the davies maps that have the gibbs
states as the stationary state would
satisfy um that that condition now
that's a stationary state so if i waits
for long enough any state would be just
driven to the stationary state in in in
time and this notion of being kind of
driven to the stationary state can be
made more precise by laying a statement
of that type that if you look for any
primitive local civilian at the distance
of the time evolved state in time so l
is the the valine the generator of the
dynamical semi group if you look at the
trace norm distance to the stationary
state that would be upper bounded by the
right hand side here where there's a
pre-factor and
an exponential factor e to the power of
minus
gamma t where lambda is the nuvilian gap
that's related to the largest real part
of the eigenvalue of this lavillion to
to come back to this this question that
in a way resembles the hamiltonian gap
enclosed system so the the mixing time
so the time you need to be
trace norm absolutely close to the
stationary state would be governed by
this this right-hand side so by the
pre-factor and the lavillion gap in the
in in the in that system
okay um
good so
you yeah this is really the spectrum
it's the gap in the spectrum but of the
the gap in the spectrum of the lavillion
that's just the generalization of if you
think of a continuous markov chain would
be gap of the of the markov chain here
it's really the spread the gap of the of
the levillion you're absolutely right
yeah so you have a minimal system we
wait and it's driven to the stationary
state and we ask the question how like
the the temporal mixing is related to
the spatial maximum could think that if
it's kind of rapidly mixing in a way in
one way or the other that kind of
correlations might be short-ranged in
the lattice in a certain
way and this can be most naturally
captured in the covariance which is well
you've seen this a million times so
that's just the largest
uh correlation function for any region a
and b in the graph
of any observable that has operator norm
node one this is the largest correlation
function that you can have that is
obviously related to other standard
correlation measures like the trace
distance or the mutual information
correlation measure that can be bounded
uh by each other of course with a
dimension-dependent uh
pre-factor in a way like with the pin
scanner quality or yes that's the
question it's always clear that there's
no uh
there's no space that's invariant
so so it's just one particular state
oh yeah well no this is not we look at
unique full-rank
stationary states
um
but this is not necessarily the case
right i mean this can also be non-unique
indeed you're absolutely right but kind
of the the leviticus we look at are
um like primitive lovelians with a
unique full rank um this is a rather
natural setting like if you think of
like a like a davies map i just have a
system that's driving to a thermal state
to gibbs state of a manufacturer that's
the type of mindset that you have in
mind
so
um
uh
so again say gab tabletonians of
uh away from phase transitions show
clustering of correlations here you have
that um correlations far away in the
lattice would be exponentially decaying
with the distance in the lattice so how
about gap leviance is the the kind of
temporal mixing inherited by a kind of
spatial mixing and a locality of
interactions in in the lattice and this
indeed turns out to be the case um
that's a that's the first result that
indeed if you have a and b non
overlapping subsets and you look
consider a local bounded lavillion with
a stationary state sigma a gap lambda
and a lead problems and velocity via say
something about this in a second then
indeed you would have that the
correlation
the correlations in the lattice would uh
decay exponentially with the distance in
in in the lattice so this kind of the
mixing time that's related to the gap
and the prefactor is related to this
spatial mixing in the lattice and you
get a decay of correlations reminding of
the ground state features of a gapped
hamiltonian
problem
yes that's the dimension and i will say
something about the the library velocity
in in a second when i kind of have a
slide on how this is proven is actually
rather simple
um
um
so how is that shown that's rather
simple you make it a time dependent
problem you go to the heisenberg picture
so ft is the time evolved observable
with l star being the dual generator of
the semi group the heisenberg picture
lavillion and then you chuck the
covalent into a time dependent part of
ft gt and a part that is a difference of
the time evolved part um and and and the
in the non-time evolved part and for the
first sec apart you make use of hurdles
inequality and like chi-squared mixing
time tools and a variation
characterization of the gap where you
find that this is upper bounded by by
these operator norm terms and an
exponential decay curvature is rather
natural because it just means that
you're driven to the stationary state
and the differences are being
exponentially quickly blurred away if
you approach the stationary state
and the second part can be captured by
means of a lee robinson bound
well these have been mentioned a million
times already these are kind of upper
bounds to group velocities in um
in in hamiltonian systems they're
usually formulated as upper bounds to to
do bounce on on operator norms of
commutators of time evolved observables
in the heisenberg picture so it means
that if you locally excite a system
there would be a causal cone and
excitations outside the causal cone
would be exponentially suppressed in the
distance
in
in the
in the lattice
and here you formulate
a
dissipative lee robinson bound that's
rather similar in spirit
um
there's many ways of formulating
dissipative
leap robinson bounds
one way of formulating is like this
where you have an observable that is
supported on a and b
and you look at the time evolved um
observer f g jointly time evolved and
compared with the ft gt individually
time evolved and it the intuition really
is that if you have an observable
sitting here and an observable sitting
there then
if the cones of these
a time evolved observers don't overlap
then they more or less factor in the
lattice with this upper bound
given by this here so if the observers
are far away and if the current stone
overlapped then there would be um this
would factor up to an exponentially
small
a correction in a similar way as for
lead problems and bounce for a ground
state problem and then you have a time
dependent problem you kind of tweak with
the time to balance the different bounds
um to
to get for a suitable time just the
bound that i haven't just
just gave
um
good
so this is not the only
uh
way one can think of
mixing
of
luvilion many body systems that's also
tighter more stringent
ways of looking at mixing there's a
stronger concept of mixing based on a
log software of concept which is a kind
of gap-like quantity in fact for a
primitive lavillion again for a
a one that has a full rank um stationary
state um it would even be bounded from
above by the leveling gap
and there's also a variational
characterization of this log servo left
um constant that's related to hyper
conductivity there's a large
classical literature on that but this
can also be made made quantum and that
gives rise to a much more stringent type
of mixing in a lavillion
many body
systems specifically if you look at any
primitive local civilian you would find
that if you time evolve the state and
look at the trace distance to the
stationary state that would be bounded
from above by such an expression with
the
with the
logs overlap constant in it in an
exponential form but with the the
logarithm of the previous uh prefactor
so if you have a finite log sovereign
constant you would get a much
tighter much more stringent bound on a
mixing times then for a finite nuvilian
gap specifically uh
well if you have for a finite log finite
nuvilian gap you would have an order n
convergence time if n is the system size
here would get a a log n system size
bound on the on the mixing time that's a
much tighter way of thinking of mixing
in lavillion uh many body
systems
and in this setting you can prove um a
number of nice things
specifically you get a mixing not only
in the covariance but also in the mutual
information between different parts
and you
where you can prove a couple of um
of our of nice things for example a
stability result for local uh lovelies
so you think of having a civilian given
with a
finite log sample of constant
independent of the system size and like
qb would be a you hammer the system
locally would be a perturbation that's
just acting somewhere on the lattice on
a region b and look at the stationary
state on the of the joint
uh level and you find that if you make a
local measurement so if you look at the
trace distance of the two stationary
states of the perturbed and the
unperturbed lovillion that they would be
very close to each other they would be
bounded from above in trace norm to a
term that's exponentially decaying in
the distance
in the latter so in other words local
perturbations perturb locally that's
it's it complements also a beautiful
kind of brother paper by adobe cubit
in a way that
and you get a stability result that um
well that that if you locally perturb a
living that would only change the
stationary state um a little bit so that
would be important
uh um in in this context of kind of uh
engineering dissipation in the sense
that if the the dissipation is a bit
wrong
then
your stationary would also be wrong so
there's kind of a stability in that
sense reminding of the stability results
of frustration free local hamiltonians
as uh
spiros and and mad and so on have looked
at also a bit yes please why is
why do you need log sobel up here not
just gap
well
there's two answers to this i mean first
of all the proof needs it
yeah yeah um second i
strongly believe that you do need this
type of mixing i come to that in a
second
um
i think
i mean there's this
these kind of ways of describing that is
slightly different i mean we look at the
finite log sample of constant in the in
the original other paper that talked
about uh the dissipated version of local
topological quantum order in a later
version they only talk about global
rapid mixing which is a vlogs overlapped
type so there's strong evidence that you
do need this type of mixing to get
stability and i comment on that later
although i'm not
this is a bit of an open question but
there seems to be strong evidence that
you do need this type of mixing but i
comment on that yeah you already
answered my question oh okay good yeah
so but you are this is an important
point you're absolutely right i mean
with this question i i agree
um okay so in this more stringent title
you can prove all kinds of things i give
another example
say you get an area law for
of course not for the entire entropy
that would be meaningless if you have a
mixed state but you get an area law for
the mutual information of a subsystem
a
with respect to the the complement of
the lattice so under conditions that are
very similar to the ones on the previous
slide you would get that the mutual
information is bounded from above by
this quantity here where you find the
the boundary area of the distinguished
region
uh where epsilon is an additive constant
that it can be made arbitrarily small
and
well there's a logarithmic dependence on
the system size here uh
then that's a bit awkward i'm not sure
whether this is an artifact of the proof
or whether this is really there
uh but other than that
sorry
because you looked at that um toby cubit
looked at it
yeah
um
okay
originally
okay good
um
indeed okay the artifact of the proof so
this is shown using properties of the
conditional mutual information that um
you would get an area law for the mutual
information
uh that reminds of the area law for the
mutual formation of thermal state so
it's kind of the dissipative variant of
the
of the thermal state motion formation
area law capturing correlations between
the system and the complement of the
of the system
um so lesson
time mixing time like temporal
uh mixing relates to spatial mixing if
the mixing is fast enough that then you
get a kind of decay of correlations in
in a certain way so the lesson is
rapidly mixing system exhibit
exponentially clustering correlations
in a way the mixing in time
related to the to the leveling gap or
the final log sample of constant is
related to mixing in space so a decay of
a short rangeness of correlations
um there's the rebellion gap or the loss
of concert that reminds of a hamiltonian
gap that role is largely taken over by
the by these gaps in in a certain way
and um
and you encounter
this kind of like mixed
fast mixing versus locality of of
interactions and that's kind of
intuitive in that sense if you have
quickly driven to the stationary state
that correlations cannot sufficiently
fast build up in time to to make
long-range correlations so that's kind
of an intuitive picture of how like the
mixing in time relates to the mixing in
space and also it's a kind of quantum
version of this program of time mixing
versus spatial mixing that's a rather
complete program in in the classical
markov chain uh
markov chain world and i think fernando
has also generalized that and given a
talk i think two weeks about such
settings um here at the at the program
yeah with myself yeah yeah
indeed so there's two different regimes
the finitely willing gap road and the
finite locks overlap constant world with
rather different implications
um which is a true quantum feature
that's absent classically it's only
there in the quantum world and it's also
absent in three thermionic systems where
one can also kind of
uh slaughter the entire problem in all
general reality whereby only has this
more stringent kind of locks overlap
type mixing and the other thing is it is
absent so this is kind of the the lesson
of the
26 minutes oh that's good the lesson of
the first part of the talk
um
of
correlations
in space versus in in time so let me end
this
first part of the talk with a bit of a
an open question or a crime story that's
um emerging here
um
like one of the applications of this is
to think of
um optimal dissipative encoders to do to
think of quantum memories one can think
of optimal dissipative encoders
preparing through dissipation say a
torque code
and this has been looked at for example
in a beautiful paper by dengues kernig
and pastovsky where they looked at the
time to prepare a topologically ordered
state to be of the order l for an alba l
lattice well that unique order l is
clear from a lee robinson bound but they
also show that what order l time is
enough to prepare the state yeah this is
a good this is good news
um
that over it also relates to aaron's
question the thing yet is that
huh for stability you need
this
uh finite log sub alpha constant which
gives rise to a
a conversion speed of log l not of l
yeah so you have this kind of awkward
tension between these concepts that
either you have topological order where
you need an order l convergence time
like a finite lavilion gap but for the
stability you seem to need this finite
log solutive constant which gives rise
to a log l conversion speed so you're
kind of too quick then not even every
part of the lattice could have talked to
every part in the lattice and you cannot
even build up topological order in time
so this seems to be a bit of a tension
between these concepts of uh either
having topological order or stability in
the lattice which
uh seems to be an important uh open
question to be overcome to think of
reconciling that and think of
dissipative stable passive quantum
memories in one way or the other which
would be a big
application
of all this maybe full stability is too
much to ask for maybe you could think of
preparing a state and having stability
only in a suitable subspace
to reconcile these two pictures maybe
but that would be an important open
question
i'm even a bit fast 28
so i'll come to the second and last part
of the talk
unless there are urgent questions
on this
okay
correlations in thermal states coming
back to the original question
of um
of the of the of the very beginning
um and there's many motivations for that
um
i start
with
the more physics-y motivation of that
related to the concept of locality of
temperature asking at what length scales
temperature is actually defined and
that's there's a huge discussion in the
physics literature people i have all
kinds of small structures like nano
devices they put a thermometer there and
they ask questions of the type at what
length scales could even meaningfully
speak of a
of a temperature
so this is a bit blah blah
so a more
stringent version of speaking of
locality of temperature how this is
usually um
set up or defined would be say if you
have a kind of lattice model and their
constituents are not interacting at all
then if you make a local measurement
and you would find expectation values at
this local measurement that would be
compatible with a certain dip say of a
certain temperature then you would
assign that temperature to that given
state yeah and then you kind of say that
this part has that temperature when you
make a local measure
of course it's only meaningful if
there's no interactions in the model
whatsoever
but if the model is interacting
how would you like what value of
temperature would you assign to the
local measurement that seems not so
clear and the way this kind of locality
of temperature question is usually
stated is that you think of a kind of an
interactive model of a buffer region
and you would say that if the local
expectation values in a certain part a
would be compatible with the entire
state being a gibbs state at a certain
temperature then you would assign that
temperature to the to this part would
say this has that temperature
yeah but of course
the problem is clear right
but of course it seems
uh
far from clear like how large that
buffer region
uh has to be
it's not even clear
like if you make a larger larger buffer
region that the
sequence of assigned
temperatures would even be convergent so
how large does the buffer region
have to be and and it kind of
is is that even a finite finite sequence
that relates to kind of locality of
temperature question in in in this
precise way and again as we will see but
i will defer that a little bit later
this again relates to a certain
clustering of correlations question now
for not for
stationary states but for gibbs states
in a many body
so again
to come back ground states of gap
laboratories have clustering correlation
so is there not a levine analog in
stationary states but is there a thermal
analog in
gibbs states and thermal states of many
body systems also coming back to the
original question at the very beginning
of the talk so is there a thermal
analyzer one could even think
that
well it's of course um brutally
plausible maybe but i mean you have to
you have to show this i could think that
there might be a critical temperature
that depend
not so much on the model but only on and
not on the graph but very crude
properties of the graph
and the coupling strength may be above
which you can be sure that all
correlations in the model necessarily
cluster exponentially
so if you're hot enough
you will get necessarily a clustering of
correlations in a thermal quantum many
body state one could think that this is
the okay so this is kind of a thermal
version of a lee robinson bound in a way
like a
yeah like we looked at
kind of living in versions of of leap in
broadcast
so this is a long-standing open question
or maybe long-standing is a bit of an
over-exaggeration of course there's a
long tradition of asking that type of
question specifically a lot is known for
classical models and for continued
models and also in one dimension this is
totally hammered down by beautiful paper
by iraqi but much less fewer insights
into quantum lattice models and we look
at that question in all generality um
building on on matt's work in fact so
one could ask is there a critical
temperature above which you know
whatever you have for all covariances
whatever you measure all correlations
necessarily cluster exponentially in
in the lattice
and well the answer is yes that's indeed
the case yeah so there's a critical
temperature
and
above that
all correlations would cluster in the
left
so here's the
technical version of saying that but
that's just saying the same thing as i
said in words so you have a local
amatonian on an arbitrary irregular
lattice
there's a kind of one size fits all
coupling strength that's i'm just just a
number and there exists a critical
temperature
that
not only not depends on the model or on
the graph but only on a certain number
namely the lattice animal constant
and then if you're above that certain
critical temperature you know that all
provides us for arbitrary observables
would decay exponentially with the
distance in the lattice in the same way
as say for a gap hamiltonian system
correlations would cluster in the
lattice here for thermal states if
you're above the critical temperature
correlations would decay exponentially
in
in the lattice so this is a general
statement
for arbitrary lattices and arbitrary
covariances um again
um
that depends only on very
elementary properties of the of the
graph
and if you're above the temperature you
know that there's a kind of locality of
interaction of correlations or
correlation functions with cluster
exponentially in the lattice
so what is this lattice animal constant
well the lattice animal that's a
connected set of edges
that's clearly a highly common
rhetorical flavor to that problem if you
look at each of the valve minus beta h
and h is a local hamiltonian you get all
these hamiltonian terms so a lettuce
animal is like this
maybe it looks
like an animal it means um
up to your uh
your fantasy that's an animal that's
another animal
and uh well that's a connected set of
edges and
while plausibly
the
number of
lattice animals with a certain
cardinality grows exponentially with the
cardinality of the of the set
unsurprisingly the lattice animal
constant it's just the the growth
constant of that so the smallest alpha
such that m a n the cardinality of like
the number of lattice animals of a
certain size is smaller than alpha to
the power of m
this is
finite for any regular lattice
um for a cubic lattice and d dimension i
think it's 2 times d times e also if d
is the dimension of the cubic lattice
and they can be
bounded from above
not for expander graph but like for
regular lattice seasons would be a
finite number this is the only number
that enters the argument so that's the
number that fixes the critical
temperature above which you know that
if you're above the critical
temperatures correlations would cluster
in the lattice
so this is a bit of a technical argument
um
but i give kind of a a high level um
flavor of this uh okay given with the
the intuition of this argument
and this is as follows
you have
you look at well this is the generalized
covariate where there's a parameter tau
on the problem i would say about this
in a second
powers satos one okay that's the
standard covariance
now this is a
obviously quadratic polynomial in row
so any quadratic polynomial can be
written using the swap trick as a linear
function on two copies of the state
that's kind of the swap trick sometimes
called um any
polynomial k can be written over k
copies of this thing so you use the swap
trick but not once but several times
that's for reasons to be stated later so
you write the covariance over four
copies row row row row on the state
with you the swap operators where you
have f and g being the the local
observables so that's kind of the tensor
network picture of the expression that
you have if you compute the covariance
off of the state
now this is an expression over four
copies of the state of the hilbert space
the four fold copies of the hilbert
space
so you have a hamiltonian
uh because these are all gibbs states h
twiddle that lives on four fold the
the hilbert space and this is like a a
um
well a gibbs state that that's a gibbs
state of a larger amaton and a larger
set and on this one you make you know
use of the the cluster expansion of this
new hamiltonian so you kind of expand e
to the power of minus beta h twiddle
and then you get this combinatorical
chainsaw massacre of all the terms
appearing when you uh expand out all
these terms
of this of this local hematology on the
four-fold copy of of the state
but the trick is the way why this is
kind of on this four-fold copy is that
that simplifies the combinatorials of
the problem significantly and one can
prove that if you look at all the
clusters that emerge in this
combinatorical problem that
um all the clusters that
connect only to a but do not touch b
or only connect to b but do not touch a
they will give exactly zero contribution
to the to the expression
and i can also show that um
uh
that the only path that contribute are
those clusters that combine that connect
um
connect a and and b and then one can use
um matt's truncated cluster expansion
that kind of
organizes the term that you have by um
the length of the cluster and asking
whether you have an edge of the set f in
the in the
combinatorical world and you make you
finish the combinatorical argument and
then you find that um if you're above a
percolation threshold then the long
words would be exponentially suppressed
and that would give rise to this
exponentially a clustering expression on
the covariance that i mentioned earlier
this kind of the high level argument
of this of this of this proof that you
you
formulate as a problem in a high
dimensional system using multiple times
of the swap trick you make it a
combinatorical problem you look at the
different uh paths that appear and then
the last step apply and the the
torquated class expansion of mat it
discussed in the context of matrix polar
operator um approximations in high
temperature states that's kind of the
the outline
of this of this book but the details are
rather rather involved
let me use the final minutes of this to
give
applications of this
um
how this can be used
one use of this is to think of
a
universal upper bound to face transition
points in
thermal many body systems it's not only
universal but in a way it's kind of
super universal because it does not only
depend on the on the hamiltonian or the
universality class or so but it does not
only not depend on the hamiltonian and
not on the graph but only on the lattice
animal constant of the graph so it's
kind of a super crude super universal
upper bound to any phase transition
point that you can have in a thermal
state of a quantum antibody system
that's a kind of a nice
useful this kind of the the complement
of the interesting region so to say so
that's kind of the reason the region
where there can be no thermal phase
transition anymore
and if you look at that for example for
the
ferromagnetic 2d isotropic easy model
that matt mentioned also in his talk
without external field you find that
this crude one size fits all upper bound
would be uh well give the value
24.58 whatever that comes out of this
this expression
whereas the actual phase transition is
known to happen at 2.27
yeah
well this is not brutally tight
but one should not um
should not forget that it does not even
not depend on the model or not on the
hammer tone and not on the graph but
only on the lattice animal constant of
the graph and then it's not so bad that
you're kind of
well the order of magnitude off to
really show where any phase transition
point can happen in that kind of model
um
to kind of bound the the region where
the the phase transition physics can
possibly happen so that's kind of one
application of this to find a bound to
curry temperatures of interactive models
in
many body systems at thermal states
the second is the length scale of
temperature problem that i anticipated
at the very beginning this can be made
precise as follows that
you
okay
you have a mini body hammertonian
you look at a region a
and you look at the buffer region around
it that links to the question discussion
that they had over lunch uh yesterday
yeah so you have this this kind of
finite term and this part here is just
the the connecting parts that connect
this buffer region to the rest of the
lattice that's
hi and the
error you make in the expectation values
on the full gip state of the many body
system compared to the gibbs state and
if you only look at the buffer region
would be
exactly given by this quantity here this
is an equality not an inequality
where you find a covariance
over this well generalized covariance
that's where the parameter tau comes in
over um this interaction hamiltonian for
this family that just
ramps in
that interaction from having no
interaction and having the full minibody
hamiltonian
yeah
so you can relate the kind of locality
of temperature problem and the
truncation problem to a question of
covariances in the many money model and
if you
that would be actually interesting to
see whether this can be applied also to
the to the ground set context but if you
apply that here you really find that
if you use that result on the
covariances mentioned earlier you really
find this locality of temperature
uh
problem that
there's a length scale that's exactly
given by the length scale of the
previous theorem and on that length
scale temperature is defined you just
defines the buffer region
if you have that then that's the region
at which you can meaningfully speak of a
temperature that's kind of the thermal
length scale and that can also be used
in rigorous approaches to quantum
thermodynamics and canonical typicality
of the type of question that mets
conference in aspen last week was
actually addressing so that can be used
to get
length scales of temperature in the high
temperature element
obviously it also relates to stability
of high temperature thermostats if you
have a here if you make a hamiltonian
perturbation there then you will not
feel it very much so all this gives rise
to a stability theorem for
high temperature thermal states of many
body systems in in pretty much all
generality that one can dream of except
in the high temperature
limit
it also means
as an immediate corollary that
one can compute local expectation values
of high temperature many body
hematurians in like in p in in
polynomial time
well trivially now because you just you
know what error you make you cut out
your piece and you compute expectation
values so
high temperature expectation values of
local observables are in p can be
efficiently computed for an arbitrary
letter for arbitrary hamiltonian in this
sense this is an efficiently solvable
problem
it also gives rise to a guideline for
quantum monte carlo if you sample out a
system at any temperature you know what
kind of finite size system you need in
order to faithfully sample the the monte
carlo problem for a given error so it
also gives a guideline to to monte carlo
sampling problems in in in gibbs states
of many body systems
um so this guy goes uh mostly to match
so one finds also a matrix product
states approximation which is efficient
in 1d so that's the mixed state version
of a matrix product say to button to mix
states in in
for an arbitrary lattice is not
efficient but it still gives rise to a
sub exponential
uh
the bond dimension of the many body
system
and finally all this
also works for fermions for interacting
firmness like for the hubbard model one
can go through the entire proof and one
would not as as is like aaron and and we
discussed on like having long range
strings or so this does not appear so
the entire proof also works for local
fermions of the lattice and again you
find all the theorems can be also
written out for interacting fermions
with the same
constraints on locality and so on and
that generalizes earlier results on like
covariance matrices of interactive
familiarity models that matt has also
looked at some time ago i think 45
minutes i'm up
so
lessons
we look at the question of a length
scale at which one can speak of a
temperature we found that
kind of the low energy physics might be
complicated but
high temperature states have always
clustering of correlations that's a very
crude property of the model only kind of
the lattice animal constant entering if
you're above the critical temperature
all correlation functions necessarily
cluster exponentially in the lattice so
this is kind of the
the the easiest setting
of a mini body model and specifically
that means that one can efficiently
compute local expectation values of
arbitrary local observables of arbitrary
lattice models and arbitrary lattices in
the high temperature limit so in this
sense
uh
high temperature states are easier one
can compute local expectation values of
arbitrary local observers in arbitrary
local hamiltonian
problems
which brings me to the end of the talk
we looked at
kind of hamiltonian complexity inspired
questions but on
open and thermal many body systems we
first looked at the question of
lovilians and kind of notions of
lovillian complexity that's on the one
hand inspired by
kind of more practical
or engineering type questions whether
one can use of dissipation to prepare
states make dissipative quantum memories
to think of dissipative controlled many
body dynamics in the lab
it's an interesting arena to study many
body problems but on the other hand also
to kind of complete this program of
relating time mixing to spatial mixing
that's a complete program in the
classical world to push that to the
quantum world and then look at kind of
mixing times versus spatial correlations
in the in the quantum anybody setting
we found that there's a clustering of
correlations if one has a lavillion gap
there's an area law if one has this more
stringent notion of a finite log super
left constant as a tighter concept of
mixing
and we found this kind of crime story of
well preparing for biological order
that's perfectly possible with
dissipative dynamics but there's this
kind of tension between having
topological order and stability in this
many body
problems it seems to be an exciting open
problem to to look at and an an
important question to to be resolved to
think of dissipative topologically
protected quantum memories in in low
dimension and finally we looked at the
temperature problem and found that
temperature is intensive
for high temperatures and correlations
in thermal many body states are
finite we get the cluster of
correlations above a certain critical
point for arbitrary lattices arbitrary
hamiltonians and so on that critical
dimension or temperature only depends on
the lattice animal constant if you are
above that
everybody is dead and all kind of phase
transitions are below
and that brings me back to the
question of the beginning of this
workshop
does the exponential complexity of
general quantum systems persist
at
high temperatures
and the answer is no thank you
questions
yes
can you give me some sort of feel for
what logs level up does the gap doesn't
do and some
i sort of have a feeling of the gap in
terms of driving down
the eigenvectors but they don't
i
um
yeah well like um what is it tightest
more stringent boundary to mixing like a
hand-wavy way is say if you look at
um
like the relative entropy distance of a
time evolved state of a open system to
the stationary state you let that evolve
in time you plug in the lavillion and
you express the derivative of this
relative entropy type expression
in terms of relative entropy then you
get kind of tighter entropy based bounds
not in terms of the the one ohm but red
entropy based bounds and those bounds
give rise to these more stringent uh
types of faster mixing in terms of that
locus level of concept that's kind of
the the hand wavy base kind of a more of
an entropic
type of mixing than uh
spectral type of mixing that's kind of
the intuition that you have here so
there's kind of a quantum version of
this
more
stringent like entropic type
and mixing of the manual system that's
kind of the
way
yes
what do you mean by general quantum
system
oh
that was i didn't write that that was in
the
on the web page of the the workshop what
what do you mean
oh
um okay um
i mean
a local
minibody
hamiltonian on a regular graph
so this sense is setting up lattices
setting of lattices okay in this sense
well that's a kind of among these
questions i would delete general then
yeah yeah yeah
of course yeah i mean i put it there
because i that was matt's
question i guess or your question yeah
maybe just you accepted expander graphs
uh from the discussion you said they're
not but
about the degree of expanded grief would
have a bounded exponent for lattice
animals so
what's the distinction you're drawing
oh
no don't make any distinction i just
mean whenever there's a finite letter
and a constant then
or you can derive these results
i'm just saying that i know for any
regular graph the compound that the
black animal would be bounded
i just uh
i had to accept the expander graphs and
so they wouldn't work on the
dependencies
i mean
the
last enema constant is surely not
bounded on an expanded graph but it
can't be larger than the degree of the
yeah
oh then it's also fine yeah i mean
whenever that's about finite then that's
that's fine but i mean that's the
theorem yeah i know that i'm not 100
sure of whether does anybody know matt
maybe like is there graphs
i mean you can often you could just
compute them as i said for cubic laptops
you really get exactly two times d times
so these numbers are known it doesn't
tie books on one platform
will be easier
yeah yeah
other questions
oh thanks again